[Musique étrangère],
vous voyez en quelque sorte comment ça pulvérise le long
du trottoir et de l'allée et non sur
l'herbe, donc l'enquêteur de course 8776 est aujourd'hui le
lundi 24 avril 2023 à 70 heures.
[Musique]
la plupart des gens, euh, corrigent le problème assez
rapidement, la plupart des gens ne laissent pas  cela donne lieu à
une amende dans la plupart des cas, ils ont deux
semaines pour remédier à la violation de la course à l'eau
qui se produit.
[Musique]
à l'étranger,
nous avons vu la consommation d'eau diminuer dans notre
communauté de plus de 30 pour cent
tandis que notre population a augmenté de
plus de 50 pour cent, donc  nous avons vraiment
inversé la tendance en ce qui concerne la
croissance démographique et l'augmentation de la consommation d'eau
[Musique]
merci